Okay.
He is Professor of Marketing
at NYU Stern School,
and this is the host of the
Prof G Pod with Scott Galloway.
Scott Galloway is back with us.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-How are you?
Okay. She's a co-host of
The Five on Fox News,
and head of research
at Bustle, Jessica Tarlov.
Jessica, how are you doing?
-Finally got you here.
-Yes.
Okay. So I wanna start off
with this.
Mike Johnson.
I know everyone is saying
"Mike Johnson,
my insurance agent?"
(LAUGHTER)
No, the other Mike Johnson.
He's the Speaker of the House
now.
So, I've been using this phrase,
"slow-moving coup,"
about Trump since before
he got elected the first time.
And a lot of people
were laughing.
I see a lot of people
use it now.
And every time we
don't completely lose
our way of government,
somebody says,
"Oh, well where's your
slow-moving coup now?"
It's slow.
That's my answer. It's slow.
But this--
what happened this week--
I remember I did a very
dark editorial like 2022,
like the last one of the year
after that election, saying--
because we all thought the
Republicans were going to win--
and I said,
what's going to happen
is that the people who
were not in place in 2020
that Trump tried to get his
bidding to overturn elections,
the John Raffenspergers
of the world, who said,
"No, I can't find you votes."
They're all gonna get replaced,
and it didn't happen then.
But, that's kind of happening
now with Mike Johnson,
the ultimate election denier,
and now all the Republicans,
it took them 22 days
to get this guy.
But now they finally got
the guy who's Trump's guy.
You know, it takes time to get
your people, to infiltrate them
into these positions.
But I'm sorry, I think
that thesis still holds.
And I think,
is this the moment--
let me ask you the question,
the Republican party is just
the MAGA party now, right?
This--
I think so.
I felt that way for a while,
and there were a few
kind of glimmers,
and I think Kevin McCarthy
was like this fancy shiny object
that a lot of people thought--
(CHUCKLES) Never heard him
described that way, but...
-(LAUGHTER)
-JESSICA TARLOV: Well...
He's handsome, he's charming.
He's the number one Republican
fundraiser out there, right?
Even in the last quarter,
he raised 14 million dollars.
He's the Nancy Pelosi
of the other side
in terms of raising money.
BILL: Wow.
-Well...
-(STAMMERING) I-- I don't--
This is a side of him
I never thought of.
Well, that's what
I'm here to deliver.
BILL: I see.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
-No. I just--
having spent a lot of time
in the conservative ecosystem,
-these are things that I
pay attention to.
-BILL: Right.
Why is this one more useful than
this one, for instance.
And Kevin McCarthy
comes off as someone normal.
He is not normal, right?
He's someone who had a day
where he said, you know,
Donald Trump is responsible
for January 6th.
And the next day,
he was at Mar-a-Lago,
throwing back martinis
and hanging out with the crew.
-So--
-(CHUCKLES) Yeah.
But this guy also has
a sheen to him, right?
He doesn't present
like what you would think.
Last week, we thought it was
going to be Jim Jordan, right?
Has no proper clothes, you know,
sits like this. Whatever.
And then, we get this guy
who's a lawyer,
who has a long career
of going after these
kind of social issues.
You already mentioned it
in the monologue,
about the sodomy laws,
criminalizing homosexuality.
He was-- In the election
integrity front,
he wasn't just someone
who signed on.
He was an architect of the plan
to get our votes thrown out
in Pennsylvania and Georgia
-and Michigan.
-BILL: Yeah.
He is so much more frightening
in that sense.
But I do think, and obviously,
want to hear what you guys
think about this as well,
I think it is a good thing
for Democrats
that he was made Speaker,
because everything
is laid bare now.
If you listen to his interviews,
you know exactly
who this party is,
and Democrats
can run against that.
It's harder to run against
-Kevin McCarthy...
-BILL: Right.
...who might feel
more normal to you.
SCOTT GALLOWAY: We keep--
(APPLAUSE)
But we keep hoping,
"Oh, this time it'll show them
for who they are."
This is just enormously
disappointing.
We are-- We are normalizing
climate change.
We are normalizing
antisemitism.
And we are normalizing
a kicking out of the legs
of the stool of democracy,
central to our democracy.
Regardless of what you think
about our country,
it's the best of its kind
so far, hands down.
Democracy, the pillars of that,
are one,
the peaceful transfer of power.
And this guy was an architect
of trying to arrest that
in a society that is secular.
And when a guy gets this nod,
and says that God ordained it,
I'm like, "Well, boss,
whose god is that?"
Because this is
the whole point here,
is that we separate
church and state,
that we believe in
the peaceful transfer of power.
And the reason
this guy is Speaker
is none of us had the time
to read his resume
and realize
he's David Duke Lite.
BILL: Well, we did now.
(APPLAUSE)
Well, I don't-- I don't know
if he's David Duke Lite.
I read today he has
an adopted Black son.
-JESSICA: Yep.
-I don't think David Duke
would do that, but he is--
but he is a religious nut.
He was the lawyer for
Alliance Defending Freedom.
This is from their literature.
They seek to recover
the robust Christian domic
I don't know that word.
You're a professor,
maybe you do.
Christian-- Christendomic
theology of the third, fourth,
and fifth centuries.
You know, maybe the fifth.
(LAUGHTER)
Something a little more recent.
But the third and fourth?
(LAUGHS)
I mean, that--
He uses the phrase,
"the so-called separation
of church and state."
This-- See, this is
the alliance of-- this is--
I hate to, you know, fascism,
the word is thrown around,
but it's always the far right
church folks meet with
the corporate power folks.
That's Mussolini, that's
all these fascist states.
And this is-- now that--
And of course,
Trump doesn't give a shit
either way about religion.
-He'll say whoever likes him...
-JESSICA: Right.
...he will,
"Sure, I'm down with--"
So he's, of course,
gonna just cave on
all this religious nonsense,
from the fifth century,
we're going back to now?
So--
Look, the biggest threat,
I think,
to civilization right now
isn't a murderous autocrat.
Putin, that's a threat.
Or jihadist, that's a threat.
The biggest threat I believe
is political extremism
in the greatest force
in the world.
And that is on the far left, we
have apologists for terrorism,
and on the far right,
we now have a Speaker
who is claiming
that school shootings--
shootings are a function
of them teaching evolution.
-BILL: Yes.
-We are literally being torn
apart internally,
and we no longer are going to
have the fabric and the muscle
to occupy the position
we command.
And that is the greatest force
in the history of the world.
This is our problem. We're
rotting from the inside out.
When you're this much
of a religious fanatic,
there is no room
for real democracy.